[Music]
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie have come
to an arrangement you and your children
are your best friends it's kind of a
it's a nice life amid a heated custody
battle over their six children a source
tells et the exes have reached an
interim custody arrangement according to
the sources Olli and Pitt had a planned
custody hearings though it was no longer
necessary after reaching the agreement
quote the interim arrangement was agreed
upon by both parties after it was
recommended by their custody evaluator
the source also tells et Angelina is
enjoying the last few days of summer
before school starts she is helping the
children heal with their father we are
in forever we'll be a family after a
second source close to the situation
says a more permanent custody deal has
yet to be decided
quote nothing has changed Brad and Angie
are just trying to be amicable for the
children in a court filing earlier in
August the actress accused Pitt of not
paying any meaningful child support for
a year and a half Pitts lawyers filed
their response one day later where he
denied that claim and said he'd paid
Jolie over nine million dollars since
their September 2016 split a separate
source recently told et that the two are
far from the finish line when it comes
to their ongoing divorce that's life is
a challenges and you got some Appeals to
face and you know it's scary for a
moment and then you look at your options
and you make the best decision you carry
on